gang the middle class famous store is
about to kick in the high gear baby
we're talking about a fun time mix of
stand-up comedy play a little ayg with
the crowd great way to introduce new
people to the show so grab your best gal
grab your best guy grab the bozos grab
the homies come on out and see the gang
oh yeah we're going to be in red bank
new jersey seattle portland kansas city
springfield st louis nashville but then
we're going to indianapolis and also
this friday the week you're hearing this
june 17th we're doing an ayg and friends
show in new york city stand-up showcase
ticket links are in the description get
em we'll see you there peace welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that they're good to be
classy yeah they're just a big old piece
of trash i'm your host states foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at antoni's basement she got
picked up last night yeah grand theft
auto yikes stole a city bus what are you
gonna do so we'll see her in about six
weeks pending on good behavior my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me he is the ceo of ru garbage a bit
of an international businessman himself
he's the prince of park avenue but
always the king of the boardwalk give it
up for kippy kevin james ryan hey gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate view subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
as you know those numbers are true
cooking then the greatest website of all
time www.patreon.com
are you garbage check it the [ __ ] out
love that money
and having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good give it up for
t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen ladies and
gentlemen what's up dudes we got a hot
one dude it's a historic day it's our
first [ __ ] race car driver dog let's
go this is a big [ __ ] dale junior in
here
look at him old smokey i like it
gang we couldn't be more excited and i
mean could not be more excited to have
our incredibly and i mean [ __ ]
incredibly special guest here with us
today
for the first time he is a behemoth a
monster stand-up comedian podcaster and
now author and let's not forget
multi-millionaire i'll tell you that
right now kids got a little bit of
[ __ ] quiche on them
he has multiple stand-up specials out
including thrilled white girls with
cornrows completely normal mostly
stories disgraceful in 2020's bull hog
of course he is the co-host of your
mom's house two bears one cave and of
course he is the owner operator of ymh
studios down here in austin texas let's
cut the [ __ ] he's one of the biggest
one of the [ __ ] baddest he's the boss
of bosses the capo de capo how hefty
they have these
ladies and gentlemen do me a favor give
it up for tom cigar
thank you man thank you guys very much
thank you very much quite an
introduction i know well
he loves the intros that's a nice intro
man that's how it goes
feels good
thanks for coming thank you for coming
i'm very excited to be here man give us
a scoop what's the best
he said that kind of like a psychopath
i am i'm excited [ __ ] anton sugars
jesus christ
i am peanuts this is fun dude
i like hanging out with comics it's
always
yeah it's the best uh what's the back
story on tom segura give us the origin
where'd you grow up give us the whole
deets okay there's there's a lot of
moving parts first of all you know my
dad was a a a white american dude and he
married a peruvian woman okay so he went
down there was like i like this [ __ ] he
took it back yeah um old school he
wrapped this one up
yeah yeah get this kid off i'll wear
this one out get her off that [ __ ]
donkey and bring her over here so
he can put down the pineapple you just
come with me no english dude i'm like
like what the [ __ ] man like at first
sight
he saw those [ __ ]
and he was like i am in so
he um yeah they so let's see they i was
born in cincinnati okay um i lived there
for the first nine years in a suburb of
cincinnati called fairfield what'd your
dad do he so he was working for a
company called byron jackson with which
sold like uh pipes i think that sounds
like an old baseball player yeah and a
hell of a relief pitcher that buy it
quit that job okay to start at like
entry level merrill lynch broker all
right um but like in that that was 19
like 76 or five and it's like you make
18 grand a year it's like you know you
gotta really hustle yeah but he worked
he stayed with them for 40 years so he
uh company man moved on up and he went
from brokerage to management and that's
why we moved a lot so i moved when i was
nine we moved to a suburb of minneapolis
called plymouth okay because he became
the sales manager of that office okay
three years later two years later we
moved to milwaukee he became the manager
of the milwaukee branch okay then we
stayed there from uh
let's see we moved there when i was 11
we left and i was halfway through my
freshman year in high school my dad
would not let me
we would not move the family until
football season was over he's like you
cannot quit on the team that's crazy
i'm a [ __ ] freshman in high school
dude so like yeah he was like this is
like a war announcement
you will not abandon the [ __ ] troops
go out there and do your workouts and
shut up we went one and nine anyway
yeah
the season ended and then he allowed the
family freshman football freshman
football jesus christ he's like you
can't quit on the phone he's a man of
honor yeah so we moved to vero beach
florida from there okay and that's what
halfway through my freshman year in high
school and then they stayed there i
finished high school there um and then
um you were the new kid rolling in
yeah that was the shittiest move oh that
happened because that's midway through
freshman year in high school you feel
like you're established everything is
like you're supposed to everything and
you got to start over again that one
sucked the most everybody thought you
were a narc probably not kidding also
this [ __ ] face is kind of police like
sure like his dad was an fbi agent i got
it in the [ __ ] here bald you got a
full beard
i did i had a beard and everyone later
told me they're like
when you would say like where like where
are you the party like there's no point
i don't know what you're talking about
you're walking around in a sport coat
yeah they're like we thought you were
like 23. i was 14.
i mean i did i had facial hair i was a
pretty big kid sure so they're like
there's no way this kid's freshman yeah
also you don't really have a backstory
you were constantly moving like where'd
you come from i was in uh you know
minneapolis my mom's peruvian sure blue
eyes sir
sure whitest guy here yeah for sure so
then i went to uh i don't know i went to
college in north carolina a small school
called lenoir-rhyne really small the
only school i got into play sports no
okay um i uh
i graduated from there what'd you major
in communications uh it's like i just
yeah don't want a major
check mark
i manage the radio station for a year
there you go that's pretty good um what
would you get on your sats if you don't
mind me asking a 10 30. solid solid four
digits is all right yeah that's not bad
it's all right um for our crowd that's
pretty good then by the way that was
like no no trying sure so i was like i
gotta try so i did the study and
everything i went back and i got like a
nine six
i'll take you 10 30. that's like take an
std test yes yeah you know the answer
you want and you get out of there
[ __ ] i left uh so i graduate i go to
work
uh in real estate my buddy is renting
apartments in boston it is a [ __ ]
racket i did not know that this is how
it works so in boston
what happens is
at the time there's 61 colleges and
universities so there's a constant
housing need that never ends right
because the students and also just you
know it's a major city
so all the the apartments have you know
list their places they call a real
estate office and they go
you know here's here's what's available
you as a realtor as long as you pass the
test you take me to show me the the
place
and then every single place had the same
rule you play first month first last and
then equivalent to one month to the
realtor
and then i get half of that with the
office so i'm out of i'm i'm just out of
college and i don't know anything about
boston so everyone is like what's this
neighborhood like i'd be like i love it
yeah totally not racist yeah
they said charlestown you can't they
would tell you things like robin banks
you can't say um
uh this is a safe neighborhood you have
to say i feel safe here
yeah whoa they're like it's twelve
o'clock on a tuesday yeah like i feel
safe come back at two in the morning on
a friday see how safe you feel but it
was the here's the thing how did how was
it boston though your buddy so my buddy
his family was from there and they had
this this real estate connection damn so
he brings me up and i hang out and like
i'm there seven eight weeks and i'm
making like thousands of dollars a week
right out of college that's crazy but
i'm like i can i could just feel that i
don't want to do this like even though i
know
i'll make six figures immediately doing
this i'm like i don't want to do this i
don't want to
be a realtor i just don't so i leave
there and i go work for america's most
wanted in uh i have heard this yes in uh
dc what tracking down cases what are you
doing yes no you're not well i'm the i'm
the researcher of one of the lead
research people so what happens is did
you meet john walsh yeah that's how you
got the job oh what you get him up in a
bar all the time
yeah i ran into john walsh uh when i was
in college his daughter was taking a
tour of the school i was at and i went
up to him and i was like i'm from the
same area and all this and he was like
you got you know he's i was like i do
communications he was like if you want
an internship call this number damn and
so i called and i got the internship and
that was while i was in college when i
graduated they were like you can come
work now for the actual show i was
working for a side show called final
justice and
sweeps week i was producing
i was producing the show in college and
for free so they're like this kid
hustles so when i go back
they're like they basically they need
stories to pursue so i'm like look this
guy he [ __ ] raped a bunch of people
he's on the run like let's go get him
you're making [ __ ] up yeah i'm just like
and i'm reading dude i'm reading like
the most disturbing just [ __ ] warping
your brain it's [ __ ] i mean like i
like crime shows and like all those
biography shows about but it's [ __ ] up
at one point
i think this is in the book that i that
that is coming out that um
they gave me
you know they give you like different
case profiles right and and then you dig
deeper and then if one is really good
then i'll i'll call the fbi and be like
you know what do you what do you have
about him
[ __ ] and they sent me
a diary of a pedophile
so it's his
personal diary of what he's doing and
you just like at the end of the day he's
like hey i'm just trying to book him on
the show i don't want his life story
yeah and then i go to the story editor
and i go
you know i lay out basically
here's the crime here's the guy here's
what he did here's why he's a you know
he's a fugitive because they want to
pursue people
and then they were like yeah we you know
they accepted it and they go um i go he
escaped
a lot of the guys especially like um sex
criminals they'll go to certain
countries where you can basically it's
easier to perform sex crimes but also to
skip out on on the justice system
so he had escaped or bribed somebody in
like costa rica so that i was like
that's right and then they sent me down
there what yeah so i do i i go do the
episode i'm on an episode uh you see me
like you know they give you any heat to
go down here they gave me no they gave
me
i'm just an intern yeah they gave me a
clipboard gave me a guide and a producer
and a cameraman and you want to be on tv
here's how [ __ ] bad i was at it
though like i mean like how i'm you know
they didn't send you down to find the
guy did they no but to do the story
right so they sent me with a producer
i'm one of the like associate producer
plus i speak spanish so i'm like
translating boots on the ground yeah
there you go and we're sitting there and
they're like um
you know i meet this person and then i
meet a girl
who was like who had been abused
and i'm sitting here interviewing her
for
the show camera's over here i'm
translating and dude as she's telling me
her story i start crying
but like she's not crying right she's
like it happened to me [ __ ] and
i'm like i'm like
and i and i'm like trying to stop and
then i just look at her i'm like yeah i
can't stop like i just keep crying and
then like one of the camera guys is like
this probably not your gig yeah i don't
think i have to go back to [ __ ] being
a realtor he's like i'm like
so i do that job for a few months
i again i'm you know my first day on
that job by the way my first day
on america's most wanted as a as a full
employee is september 10 2001.
in dc
so i'm the like my next my second day of
going to work is 9 11
right and like and and so then our whole
my whole show becomes like profiling we
we just profiled bin laden every day
still looking for him yeah
and i'm like at the white house you know
what because we're doing pressers from
like you know whatever they talk all
they would talk about is terrorism so
then they would send our crew to the
white house so i would just be sitting
on the lawn you know that west wing long
just out there calling friends like i'm
at the [ __ ] white house and then
people would be like you know they can
hear you right i was like yeah like i'm
just like yeah dude this place is
[ __ ] awesome where are you guys
drinking that
this guy's a cop i don't trust him did
boomer ever get that weed what's the
deal
[Laughter]
gang by the way the book is called i'd
like to play alone please you have to
[ __ ] check it out fantastic please do
you can get an audio book if you like to
you know listen to them ebook hard book
whatever um but
i do that for a few months and i have
the same feeling as like the real estate
thing where i'm like you know i don't
want to do this
[ __ ] right and it's like immediately
after september 10th first day and the
they gave me a three-month contract they
offered me a re-up they're like you want
to do like a year contract and i'm like
no
and i just i load up a truck and i drive
to la then i joined the ceo comedy yeah
you were like already dead set had not
yet not no i've never done st i'd hosted
a couple of things where i'm like feels
like you're doing stand-up i hosted a
talent show i'd done like improv you
know like high
school bits on america
and then communications like in college
they would do the [ __ ] lamest videos
right because you had to shoot and edit
in your videos well i would always do
comedy videos right like i was trying to
make
comedy videos
and you know my professor was like what
the [ __ ] is that right he said people
are doing like
[ __ ] that like you'd find like a local
like a videographer for like a wedding
would do sure and i was just like what
if you froze your diarrhea
so here's a compilation of car crashes
he's like the [ __ ] is this i was like
it's funny right he was like i got this
guy in costa rica you got to have a mom
so i moved there
uh january
2nd of 2002 i moved to la and then i
a few months later i signed up for the
groundlings which is like the improv
show yeah and i cause i thought i was
going to do that i thought i was going
to be like a comedy actor and then
there's stand-ups in my class
sam tripoli was in that class with me
nick wegener
he's a writer now and they were both
doing stand-up at the time and they were
like you should try stand up yeah damn
that's kind of like what'd you do on 911
they give you a half day they send you
home what happened
it was the longest it was the longest
[ __ ] day because i remember i was
putting my i was tying my shoes i was i
i rented a room at a house in college
park maryland okay right which is like
outside like 30 minutes outside yeah dc
and i'm tying my shoe i remember and
they had they happen to have like good
morning america or what one of those
locals on and it showed
uh the got like the smoke coming out i
still remember it was like brian gumbel
or someone being like they still thought
it was like a cessna they're like oh a
cessna
hit the thing and as i'm putting on the
other shoe
the uh second plane and i get in the
yeah i get in
the my my truck and i'm driving into dc
and all the radio stations are like
we're under attack and i'm like we're
not under what the [ __ ] is he even
talking about and then they're like the
pentagon got hit i'm like i'm in the
middle of the driver
and then we go in there and like uh it
was here's the thing i worked
at fox
studios local fox affiliate on wisconsin
ave in dc so when you're in a new state
like if you think if you're home
watching tv that day that's a lot there
are 100 tvs that have all the feeds
so all you hear is every feed and every
screen and we stayed there until like 11
o'clock at night so at the end of the
day everybody was just like gee
it was yeah that's a lot to take in it
was a lot of me being there like in dc
it was like damn damn that's [ __ ]
wild it was a wild day yeah man from
that to the groundlings
let's yuck it up guys
holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ] crazy uh
brothers and sisters what was the story
two sisters one's i'm the middle so okay
younger
yeah what were the family vacations like
um they
your dad started doing well right
i mean it it i remember all the
transitions
all the level ups i remember the level
ups yeah i mean like you know i remember
that you know it would be
fast food it was kmart it was you know
like like buying a new car or whatever
whatever yeah but i remember like it was
it was it was you know
you would be in a a certain
socio-economic group for for a while you
know a few years i mean we had like you
know
for then it was like minivans and like
like 16-hour drives you know to like
orlando jeez and that was the vacation
you would drive from like minneapolis
down there yes it was all [ __ ] yeah
they never [ __ ]
flew i mean did your mom drive or did
your dad have to bite that bullet no
really that woman is peruvian dude
no
she won't drive on the highway
still she's like the highway scares me
it moves too fast yeah she drives like
on side streets and then she's like will
you get me a car i'm like for what
she also is like always asking for like
the newest laptop i'm like you play
bridge
like just use a [ __ ] dell and she was
like you know
she's like i want the new macbook air
and i'm like why it flexible
so much capacity no i get of course like
she guilts me into getting it for her i
got her a [ __ ] mercedes get her don't
get her an old game boy i got her
mercedes
three months ago nice and she calls me
and she's like the problem is it's too
high it's like it's an suv
yeah that's how they make
and she's like uh i got a low rider
she's like i need to ask if they can put
the climbing device on
a ladder like what are you talking about
and she's like maybe i switch it for
another one i go that's on you i'm done
i'm out you you switch it for another
car holy [ __ ] yeah that's [ __ ] wild
man did she she didn't work growing up
no okay uh there was a period where she
was doing like volunteer stuff at a
school and she would always because she
you know that like her english got
better over time she would always do
things that like if they needed a
bilingual person you know like yeah
because we built in some like
some of these cities where you you know
nobody you didn't know anybody that did
so they were like we need a guy there's
this guy at the hospital doesn't know
how to
tell the doctors what's going on gotcha
could your dad speak spanish [ __ ] no she
couldn't so she taught the gir your
sisters they spoke spanish too well what
happened was she just like when she got
to the like when they married i'm like
what kind of relationship did you guys
have she knew how to say like 11 words
and they're like we had god you know
like they're both catholic
so they um they would just
i mean i just i didn't understand like
how how the [ __ ] this happened so as a
kid
when she was like at home talking to us
meaning the three kids uh-huh she would
just speak in spanish spanish always
whether it's like to clean your room or
it's time to eat or you're late for
school or it was just all spanish
spanish spanish
and then we would usually reply in
english right so it was like right all
right
but to my dad
you know she spoke never learned spanish
he knew like [ __ ]
nine words like he'd be like tango i'm
break
and one time i go i go hombre i go you
didn't i have hunger right i didn't
learn any like cool [ __ ] and then this
is like right before he died he died
like in december this is probably like
in october september so he's never said
this to me i'm like
you never like she never taught you
anything and like she's sitting next to
him and he's like well there is one and
i go what and he said
which is my lit my mouth drops open for
your [ __ ] and i was like
how about where's the beach
that's what you [ __ ] that's the only
that's great i go you only why'd you
hold on to that well now you know how
the relationships were you knew what the
[ __ ] was going on yeah holy [ __ ] gang
this podcast is sponsored by better help
let me tell you something burnout is a
real thing oh yeah you're feeling
fatigued
lay off the h and get a haircut will you
gang if you need to talk some things out
you want to reach out to better help
because they honestly can help yeah uh
symptoms of burnout can include lack of
motivation feeling helpless trap
detachment fatigue the whole nine yards
if you got it you know
talk to someone it is a game changer
yeah uh better health is customized
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to uh
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy can be matched with a therapist
under 48 hours are you garbage listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhealth.com
garbage that's betterhelp h-e-l-p-com
garbage do it yeah let's talk about
ladder ladder let's talk about ladder
let's talk about not leaving your family
holding the bag like i'm probably gonna
do yourself a favor gang get yourself a
little term life insurance and go over
to the lateral straightening out no
doctors no needles no nothing you got
the rising cost of living student debt
you're trying to buy a house you you
know you don't want to leave any
financial burden on your partner your
children's you know take care of these
kids guys you know grandma's looking at
50 g's ladders 100 digital no doctors no
needles no paperwork when you apply for
three million in coverage or less just
answering a few questions about your
health in an application you just need a
few minutes on the phone laptop to apply
ladder smart
algorithms work in real time so you find
out if you're instantly approved no
hidden fees cancel any time get a full
refund if you choose if you change your
mind in the first 30 days
uh finally since life insurance cost
more as you age now is the time to cross
it off your list so go to ladderlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage do it up
back to the show what was the uh since
you moved around a lot let's do uh the
minneapolis one what was the name of the
street that you grew up on what was the
name of that street in minneapolis yeah
[ __ ] do you remember any of them you
grew up on uh i do remember walther
drive
that's pretty classy that sounds alright
sounds like
no that was not a wealthy one though no
there was um the nicest house actually
the house had i thought i thought we
were [ __ ] cooking i mean i thought we
were like ceo
was in milwaukee okay and i think it had
oak in the address that's good and it's
nice here's the thing this is wild okay
it had a tennis court the house yeah
damn that is kind of cute that's ceo i
know so you turn onto the street and i'm
like oh [ __ ] and this is what happened
like i go and people used to drop me off
they're like is this the neighborhood's
tennis court i'd be like no shit's
alright did anybody play tennis in the
family yeah everybody started playing oh
yeah yeah
get the [ __ ] outdoors and then like and
then like skateboarders would try to
come by because of the you know like the
the surface
i'd use a pellet gun and shoot them from
[ __ ] crazy talk about new money i
like that
uh
but get them long hairs i'll get that
get out of here you [ __ ] hippie
a couple of warning shots over the net
and my dad really hated hippies so it
was like it was great he was in vietnam
oh of course really yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's a marine he [ __ ] just
yeah he really he's hippie
um the thrill of killing the enemy and
and he would be like
he wouldn't tell me about it for years
he was in combat yeah he was in combat
god damn yeah he led a platoon of 70.
jesus he's a lieutenant that's in the
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] and
so for years
years i would be like because you know
your dad's in a war you're like what was
it like in war
and he would be like yeah you know and
and they never like talk those dudes
never like they don't i think he also
was like he kept my mother
you know they had like a more
traditional relationship where like you
know what i mean like you don't like you
don't talk a certain way around
you're like sure certain people have
that gentleman yeah yeah more
gentlemanly around my mom and like you
know you talk talk with the guys like
this and when we were young he would
also also protect us from you know
saying crazy
but then like i turned 30
and i'm like really yeah i just start
keep talking about war and then
one day i'm i'm probably like
late 30s i'm like so like
what's it like though like you know like
in combat like
like shooting the enemy especially there
at that time was [ __ ] probably dice
yeah and he goes
way better than the best [ __ ] you've
ever had
he passed above he passed the baby in
spanish
you call it getting some you hear it
like in movies yeah get something
he's like did you get some and then he's
like when you got some he was like it
was a sense
of euphoria and you just you know i
would i would ask the guys would you
rather would you rather go get a blow
job right now or or blow these uh you
know these guys i don't know
don't be cut i have an uncle
yeah and they'd be like we want to get
some lieutenant like he was like and
then you just see him like [ __ ] damn
i mean they you know you get trained of
course they did so you know it's a it's
like a foreign
of course my dad was in the navy and he
was in alaska and he volunteered to go
to vietnam he was in country on like a
pbr base and he never he wasn't in like
the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah like your pop was but
he was it was dicey never said a [ __ ]
word to us about it ever yeah just every
once in a while when he would be
watching us at the house and my mom
would be at work you would turn all the
lights off in the house turn all the
flood lights on and make us sit in front
of the picture window and look out are
you being serious yeah how crazy is that
dude just every once in a while yeah
they're all night watch i think i think
his biggest thing was
when he imagine those sleepovers buddy
dude he got there in 1971 and there was
like a bunch of people there there was
like a bunch of navy guys a bunch of
airborne uh people across like the delta
or whatever but by the time he left the
last couple months he was there it was
like him and like 15 americans and the
rest were all south vietnamese and they
were they were coming so it was like i
think it was a worry of every night
that's intense dude you know the saddest
part the saddest part i think for my dad
though for like because he tells you to
tell these stories and a lot of times
they would be like just really intense
and sometimes they're really funny
is that at like towards the end of his
life like
he would start to talk about how much it
emotionally affected him and i was like
he thought that like therapy was only
for
like yeah christie's are just crazy
people yeah and those dudes put a cap on
that [ __ ] and 25 years ago one of his
friends who was a guy he met who was in
now at the same time same rank as my dad
in the marine corps
it was like you know i love therapy and
he's like yeah but your dad won't he
won't do it and i was like damn i wish
they i wish that i know man you know
like just to go
get that off yeah i think they're so
deep and it's so scarring and their
generation was so not used to it just to
even open that can yes [ __ ] yeah they
can't even start yeah did your dad smoke
no no really no
picture like a zippo later a couple of
[ __ ] reds no and uh born to kill on
his helmet he really
really despised uh marijuana
really he had like multiple stories
about
um because a lot of the troops you know
dudes being [ __ ] up falling asleep on
watching [ __ ] like that and guys he um
he told me a story of multiple stories
about uh viet cong or somebody trying to
sell
his marines marijuana and like picking
them up by their throat and like putting
their m16 in their face and i'm like
buddy she's a little reefer calm down he
made he made his marines piss
on like a big bag of it one time he's
like that's what i think about marijuana
i was like all right all right
cool i had your stash up in the room
real well were you smoking doobies in
high school yeah yikes yeah yeah yeah he
would have freaked out he would have
freaked out and i remember one time you
ever do one of these i go out on a
friday night
and and get in late right and i'm
driving my like one of my parents
it was a toyota 4runner i remember
specifically
and i remember you know i go to bed and
i'm gonna sleep in probably until like
11 or something
did i'm in a dead sleep
and at like seven o'clock in the morning
i shoot up i was like
and i run downstairs i'm in boxers i'm
just wearing boxers like what i sleep in
and my dad's
on the couch just watching tv he's just
like getting like you know breakfast
going like new stuff
and he's like hey i go hey and i just
walk outside i open the door to the
forerunner and on the center console i
left the pipe
like a pipe with weed in it and i'm like
at first i don't know how i left it or
how i remembered
then i i grab it and i go inside he's
like what are you doing now you to
explain what you just did and i just
said like some dumb [ __ ] i was like i
just you know making sure the grass was
the water lights were on that thing
i thought i saw some hippies on the
tennis court dad i was going to shoot
him i got him don't you worry it was a
level of panic
i
those old schoolers was tough to get
away with anything on yeah they knew
exactly what you were doing sure you are
all right sure buddy you know you got a
45 to your head
i'm 16 of your [ __ ]
mr sakura what the [ __ ]
everybody was scared
put a [ __ ] knife in his mouth cut his
balls off and stuck him in his mouth
you kids want some pizza
that's crazy yeah i wonder you were
scared
terrified holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up
god damn what was the grocery store that
your mom would go to maybe down in
florida since you publix publix yeah all
right yeah respectable not too good not
too bad yeah what was the high school
mascot pirates that's all right that's
fun yeah yeah it's not classy but yeah
is actually pretty tragic the morning
yeah it's kind of trashy and um in home
in milwaukee it was
the school was called homestead i think
it was
the highlanders but i don't remember
that's that's pretty sweet that's good
sir can you google it it's highland
homestead high school in mequon
wisconsin
i think so they um
they were like they were very they were
good like yeah they won state and a
bunch of different things did you play
sports in high school yeah you did play
football football and basketball yeah
did your dad play football in high
school yeah
that's why yeah football guy yeah
imagine he was probably pretty
physically he was a three-time uh state
champion olympic weightlifter whoa
yeah yeah and you're out smoking doobies
with your good time [ __ ] including
fourth in the nation at 14. god so he
was like a little freak you know i'd be
[ __ ] petrified of this man
and you know how he would um so when i
wanted to get into weightlifting i'm
like oh my dad like all we had was
trophies and everything from all his
wins
and i was like uh you know i go to do
like a power clean and he was like no
and i was like okay he goes do it like
this and then he just he did it sure and
he was like do it like that i go that's
not like coaching yeah it's not how it
works
like you can't just be like what you
need to do without being a [ __ ] that's
me you know yeah
and then he just like walked away i was
like that's the lesson
all right yeah dog angus the highlander
homestead high school in wisconsin okay
highlander okay so highlanders and then
the booty pirates in the booty pirates
that sounds like an uncle luke song
the booty pirates everybody's twerking
uh did you drink milk with dinner
growing up
no i hate milk what yeah i hate get this
guy out of here
yeah well i it made me [ __ ] i mean i
used to drink it with cereal obviously
sure normal times to drink milk not with
the [ __ ] are you lacking some tolerance
no no but it kind of just makes me
nauseous like i don't really just don't
like what are you doing the drink in the
coffee this is oat milk okay he's a
[ __ ] gentleman
so far so good
what were the pets like growing up
uh we always had at least a dog so at
first it was
first it was a
white maltese named fluffy okay okay
that escaped and my parents went and
bought the exact same dog and told us
that they found it like they found our
dog that's like [ __ ] yeah no not the
parents type [ __ ] and then uh that
tennis court if you ever come back or
how did you how did you how did you make
fluffy shows
how'd you make fluffy number two well
that's what i'm saying they went and
told us that they found fluffy but i'm
saying how did you know that it wasn't i
guess you do no it's not yeah i
certainly were like this dude that's a
labrador
what's up with the spots
i don't even know his [ __ ] name this
dog has tattoos what the [ __ ]
tails gone
so but then when we got to florida they
got kind of dog obsessed you know i
think it happens to like as kids get
older especially to the woman of course
you know so then it then they got
my dad a beagle when he was a kid and he
told us this name rocket right and so we
got a beagle okay and they named it
rocket and it was morbidly obese like
fat beagles tough luck dude i took it to
the vet and they're like what are you
guys doing to this and i'm like i'm not
the owner the parents my parents own it
and they're like this dog is so sick
it's so fat it's way fatter it's like
they feel like just
i guess whatever it wants and they're
like feed it green beans i told my
parents day one they got green beans
that was it that was the only mozzarella
sticks in here on a green bean casserole
yeah say [ __ ] it
and then they got pugs they got into
pugs okay love pugs at one point there
was five feel like once people get into
pugs they really wait hold on hugs yeah
take a step back here yeah there was
five pugs in your house four pugs and
one beagle at the same time the same
time yes how many bedrooms is the house
um when they when they had all those
dogs
it was a
four or five bedroom house your couch
must have been covered in dog hair no
because i i well i don't remember that i
don't remember that it could have been i
don't i really don't remember and then
but here's the thing
at the time they're acquiring dogs it's
like my older sister
probably like going to college
dogs are coming in people are moving out
you know five dogs is a lot who would
walk to dogs would you have to walk them
walk no
why do you think they're so [ __ ] fat
what about the dog [ __ ] in the backyard
this has come up on the podcast this is
the clean it up
me no somebody in the family or the
landscaper yeah yeah and my mom would do
a lot of that yeah and then did you have
to cut what were your chores you have to
cut the grass so i did cut grass you
know it's a funny thing it's like
there's there's a
there's like
cultures and communities where it's
normal and then where it's not and for
some reason when we were in the midwest
cutting your lawn was just routine sure
like i i cut the lawn in in minneapolis
and milwaukee for years and like and
it's like we moved to florida and
they're like what are you doing people
don't what are you doing you don't cut
the grass you hire somebody
it was just like everybody and like even
like
like lower middle income people would
have i think it's a part of it is that
it's a hundred and [ __ ] sure that's
true and so i also think there was a
time where that turned where maybe maybe
it was more affordable for landscapers
to be like hey i can come for 30 bucks
yeah okay great so i once we were in
florida i never did yard work
i know what kind of equipment were you
riding in uh
i remember we had the push and then in
that milwaukee house with the that my
dad went and got the riding mower john
deere what was it i don't remember the
craftsman it could have been a craftsman
if it was a deer you'd know it yeah i
don't know you never forget a deer tom
riding that thing around what are you
talking about you're right yeah
i would remember yeah come on everyone
remember that was the green and i was
[ __ ] i got to say it i was thrilled
to be doing that i liked it the writer
became a mature before you could drive
and like they had like [ __ ] horses
it was pretty like substance like it
wasn't enormous amount of land but it
took a while to get out there for a
while you feel empowered when you were
doing it it was great
did you ever joyride the riding lawn
mower off the property that's a bad luck
a little bit but not
not far way down a little bit didn't go
to the circle
throwing rocks at everybody yeah
[ __ ] cars there was a nazi across the
street i forgot that
you should open with that i know what
are you doing talking about your tennis
courts it took me a while to put it
together you know
he was like 90 and german and the flag
didn't give it away
and i [ __ ] you know i really click
with this guy
really got along you know
his memorabilia do you have a family
it was just it was this old german
couple and you know there's a lot of
germans in milwaukee okay
but then i mean we're talking i mean old
as [ __ ] and he was a little older than
her they i mean when i we moved there he
had to be like in his eighties and like
you know like he was a mess but like
sweet
um and sweet
hateful guy you know but like i didn't
put together and then all of a sudden
you know some time goes by and it's like
talking about oh you're in the military
you're in the war and i was like which
war were you in
i'm like oh
it wasn't fallujah i'll tell you that
i'm like i'm like wait you're 85.
what's normandy really like yeah i was
like
okay dan he was a german soldier yeah of
course they let him over here yeah i'm
sure he had he should have reported they
started can they still catch them out in
queens every now and then yeah
yeah they gotta they got a guy like a
year a couple years ago a guy living out
in like [ __ ] ridgewood queens
tooth puller i've seen those uh those
documentaries on it's fascinating oh and
they get them in argentina oh yeah
there's that one about the the guy who
he had a
nickname and there it was a whole like
i'm mistaken he was like that's not me
it was like that's right that was the
cleveland guy i think he was out in the
midwest that was fluffy i could tell you
it wasn't fluffy no but those yeah they
went to brazil and argentina a lot and
um
that was uh what's it called eichmann
was got was captured down there we got
eichmann in uh in argentina that was
fascinating yeah and it was all you know
because like if you watch these crime
stories like one of the big things about
if you commit a crime with a group of
people is that somebody wants to brag
right like if you rob a player remember
like even like goodfellas it's like
start living it up they're like don't
spend the [ __ ] money right like do
that now stop being flick get this
[ __ ] thing off see goebbels doing
that speech yeah yeah look at me
don't [ __ ] buy anything
so
but it pulls up in a pink cadillac
i'm gonna
hey
it's in my mother's name what are you
doing it was a christmas present oh my
god jesus christ okay let's talk about
that mint mobile mint mobile best in the
biz at mint mobile 15 bucks a month
don't be a bozo what do you got t-mobile
sprint like a loser getting ripped off
probably paying nine 10 grand a month
just to [ __ ] text messages
they put you in a contract for i don't
know about 47 years yeah they lock you
this is a studio deal let's go
the silent film error is over get on
[ __ ] mint mobile yeah t-mobile owns
my masters
trying to buy them back i'm trying to
re-record them like taylor's uh there's
no catching everything what's to catch
nothing 15 beans a month um
beans the secret sauce is the company
sell directly why do they serve the
wireless service
cut them out the retail stores there we
go you're off at the past peanut butter
in your mouth you got to flank these
guys
[Laughter]
alpha bravo for anyone who hates their
phone bill mobile's offers premium
service for just 15 bucks a month it
gives you the best rate whether you're
buying uh one or for a family and then
family started two
lines kind of family not bad very
nuanced nuclear
nuclear uh to get your new wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month and get that
plan shipped directly to your door for
free go to mintmobile.com garbage at
smittmobile.com garbage call your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com garbage do it kip let's
talk about sofi so phi baby i don't know
about you but i'm pretty stupid when it
comes to invest everything yeah yeah a
lot of stuff i don't know what's going
on the nft's dogecoin and elon misk i
don't know what it is but wouldn't it be
nice if there was an app
where you could get all those questions
answered mm-hmm all right your nfts your
your left-hand your efts all that stuff
they start throwing around meme stocks
and this and that i don't know what
they're talking about but sofi does yeah
so if i squares you up they take care of
you they take the guesswork out of it uh
there's no commission guesswork on
trading stocks and efts plus no account
fees or hidden fees no whether your
eater gets started started with
investing or you already know the ropes
and you just want to diversify your
portfolio a little bit they got you so
if you're a beginner get on board if
you're an expertise they still got
something for you there you go use
fractional shares to start as low as
five dollars to buy brand name stocks
even if you don't have a couple of grand
laying around you just want to buy five
bucks i don't know something there you
go whatever you like
your favorite shoe company boom buy that
open the door a little bit out the door
get hands on uh with active investing or
let sofi's number one ranked automated
investing tool or robo investor investor
take the stress out of building and
managing a diversified portfolio by
doing it for you they know what they're
doing portfolio cut through the jargon
and make investing easier with sofi
visit sofi.com garbage to learn how you
can win up to thousand dollars in stock
when you open an account that's sofi
sofi.com
garbage brokerage and active investing
products offered through sofi securities
llc member f-i-n-r-a
s-i-p-c now back to the show but [ __ ]
eichmann's son
uh barry a girl that he was on a date
with really he didn't help himself he's
like 16. he's like you know my dad is my
dad killed so many [ __ ] shoots jesus
yeah because he couldn't he couldn't
keep his back guys trying to get laid
yeah
you wanna hear a cool story
my dad killed six million people
allegedly oh you scored a touchdown at
the game huh where do you hear this
holy [ __ ] it was a nazi girl
what was your first car
your personal one you're personal we
know you're a big car guy uh my dad okay
a 199 in 96. 1896 new
uh base model ford mustang damn i loved
that car really that was a very specific
it was those yeah they were that was a
great year for them yeah that was pretty
cool now so things are going well right
before i drove that for a few months
i drove my sister's
honda accord nice um but then he got a
hatchback
no i had a hatchback oh nice stick you
drive stick i do now i didn't then
really yeah i'm surprised the mustang
wasn't a stick no and it was it was the
beginning of like that was the beginning
of the end for the mustangs well not
just that but also like there was there
had been a like by the late 90s a real
decline
in the decline was beginning massively
for manual production going down
so it was like you know
like my you know it's like three percent
yeah
and it goes down every year yeah yeah
and so like um
like it wasn't even like it wasn't even
an option they were just like no
everything's you know yeah yeah so yeah
my wife is german actually uh from
germany so she really yeah she knows i
have to do a deep dive on her family
after this i guess
no she's actually jewish but um we did
she knows how to drive stick and i feel
like the biggest [ __ ] can i tell you
over there because i can't drive you got
it you you're driving around like
[ __ ] jason bourne and i'm you got to
do it once i learned it's [ __ ]
awesome it is such a thrill awesome i
used to valet so i could do it to like
park cars i could stall a bunch of
people's nice cars yeah of course uh get
out there i remember there's no [ __ ]
there's no time there's like almost no
panic like that panic of oh out the
world's out yeah the world's coming down
on you in there and people are like
[ __ ] gone
but once you get over that it takes a
little bit it's so much fun i just yeah
my key is automatic so we're okay yeah
there you go yeah what uh what are you
rolling around in now i got a few rides
now lay it on me we got all the time in
the world sir
what's the day-to-day
what are you zipping around from the
house to the studio uh
no i got drivers no no
i have a new um
uh porsche gt3 touring
that's the day-to-day that's the that's
the that's the knock-around car yeah
that's pretty crazy
is that is that a lease you gotta lease
it no i bought that
i got a three year lease
i got a uh 997 gen one gt3 rs okay i
don't even know what that is yeah that's
a porsche okay okay i got a 718 gt4
that's another porsche okay i have a
cayenne turbo that's a porsche right
that's kind of the family that would be
yeah okay
turbo s that's a porsche damn really
what's the garage situation how many
cars d can you fit in there
right six i think
now i keep on the lawn
keeping it real
i can fit five in there okay fit five
what's with the four five where did the
first thing come from i mean i get
they're obviously great cars but uh yeah
of course
when you start once you start driving
them it really is a game changer
seinfeld is a big porsche guy he's got a
lot can you talk to him about porsches
never meet the man i've never met
seinfeld no he definitely has like i
think he leases them
he has a
wild collection yeah yeah don't go over
10 000 miles i think he has like
like a hundred and something sure did
you meet leno do you ever do cars with
leonardo yes i did his show oh that girl
was that was awesome he's a he's a
really fun guy to talk to about cars um
he's got a crazy collection
um i got a range rover that's my okay
next level up i want to get around then
i have a couple uh resto mods being done
right now you know i don't know what so
sorry performers
yeah get in the game fatty got a missile
i have like a 68 ford bronco wrestle mod
being built awesome um my stepdad's
redoing the broncos yeah those are
pretty cool yeah yeah uh will you eat in
the porsche
any of the cars
uh in the
in the car like in the car car like the
gts yeah not really no no you're also
probably not like hitting the
drive-through anymore because you're
you're running a tight ship now yeah
healthwatch was the last time you were
at a drive-through
um
that's a good question really it's been
that long and what what what's your
poison if you do go what [ __ ] yeah
that's me i tell you tuesday easy no i
[ __ ] love i love
i probably it probably was like last
year i probably hit a chick-fil-a i love
chick-fil-a
they know what they're doing over there
um but i love like my favorite
indulgence which i haven't had in a
while but is a mcdonald's fries those
are the [ __ ] piping hot everything at
mcdonald's fresh out it's great those
are the [ __ ] i mean i used to [ __ ]
just eat myself into like i think i
would just scare my esophagus like i
would eat them handfuls hot and like and
like gasp for air and then i'll be like
i wish could we get more
that's what i'm talking about by the way
mcdonald's i still remember this if you
get cause i would be obsessed about that
temperature if you get go to like any
mcdonald's and you get fries and these
they're like lukewarm and you tell them
they'll make new fries well he's big on
the lightly salted right is that oh
that's what you like
they do new ones yeah no but i i have a
trick at fast food places breaks in
after night
deep fry give me the [ __ ] um you
always make uh and you call an audible
you make an adjustment to the thing you
take something off or add something
that way they're making it fresh nice
yeah yeah little fat guy tip for you
okay yeah nice
um
will you put anything
do you have air fresheners in the cars
i don't i don't have any air fresheners
i guess if you're not eating you're not
smoking there's no real need to yeah no
i have um i have a guy come to the house
and detail the cars really yeah god damn
so i guess there's no steering wheel
cover in there i wouldn't
you have eyelashes on any of them
there's there's no beads on the scene
there's trucks truck knots
is there really
oh my god
[Laughter]
i love i love cars dude i could i mean i
i'm
seriously contemplating uh getting a
storage place oh i also have a the race
car that bird got me of course i know
that's specky 46 and a trailer we were
kind of driving on the street yeah
getting one to race against you guys yes
oh really yeah we're nice nice everybody
get your [ __ ] wife right
exactly have you ever driven on the
autobahn no never doing the autobahn
pretty cool that's gotta be it's a wild
scene that's kind of just every now and
then i'm doing a european tour uh go for
even if you're not don't dr i mean i'm
sure you because you can just rent like
a [ __ ] whatever yeah for like an hour
that'd be awesome
but like to watch them drive by you it's
wild yeah yeah yeah all right let's get
into it have you guys ever thought about
doing the gumball rally
we've talked about doing a couple things
there's some things in the works that
we're talking about as far as you know
like getting involved in what can you
like get into le mans or anything like
that they're going to mars but we're
gonna we're i think we're gonna do
something fun like race wise endurance
wise okay then we're talking oh that's
like cannonball run something like that
yeah yeah get in on that yeah you could
yeah i'll be don deluise
we should do it and not tell him just
show up
just waiting at the [ __ ] we're here
like let's go
what the [ __ ] is this we're in your
mom's jeep
you're worried about the miles i can't
i'm almost done with my mileage um you
got a fish tank at the house no okay did
you have one
sorry one growing up uh there was
certain houses where it wasn't like one
of those elaborate ones okay but there
was definitely times where like we're
getting fish there's a fish tank and is
it ever empty in the house empty fish
tank in the house that's a real tough
that's a real tough it's a bad smell
south jersey
[Laughter]
um
no i don't i don't think so i think it
was pretty much there was definitely
times you're like have they eaten
does one look a little foggy
my mom you know i do so much
any pets now for the kids anything dude
you know what just happened last week
it's funny you asked him this happened
last week so
we had we rescued a a dog
and uh we got him in 20
i think
twelve twelve or six oh wow i don't
think this has well well no no so
then um
a few years later
uh around 2015
we got one from a breeder of brussels
with brussels griffon nice if you ever
as good as it gets that dog that like uh
sure jack nicholson has right yeah um
ferdel yeah right
um
so anyway
the the rescue died in 2019
the one that we got um from the from the
breeder
it's like you know it's part of the
family we've had it we've had her for
for the time we've had kids like she was
how your kids are how old they're six
and one the youngest about to be four so
there's three turning so they know uh
well yeah so they you know uh she we got
her a few months before the six-year-old
was born okay whole life she's been
there
our young we moved to texas our youngest
had been getting
sick like
his um asthma started and it started to
like really be a thing we're like he's
always sick now we went to doctors and
they sent us you know specialists and
they get sent you to
your nose and throat and then an
allergist turns out they do
a full blood panel
he has one of the highest allergic
reactions to dogs damn
to dogs so we're like [ __ ] so i called
my mom
i was like she's like nice dog he's
coming she's she's now with my mom okay
that's not bad you can get rid of it
that's good yeah it's like yeah you
don't leave me on a burger king yeah
remember the chick-fil-a story
[Laughter]
all right not bad anybody ever been on
the local news for anything growing up
uh
are you on the local news growing up i
don't think so man okay yeah that's
classy that's pretty classy it's not
true have you been on the local news
no i wish i was though yeah like it's an
accomplishment
yeah yeah i had a couple i had a couple
of cousins that saw a house fire they
were on the news that's the best we're
bragging oh man
when they when they fill you in on the
story oh yeah
i had a cousin when the eagles were in
the super bowl down in florida like you
know comcast sportsnet or whatever like
the local philly channel went down yeah
we're interviewing people and local dirt
ball yeah they cut to him and he was
boozing heavy at the time yeah and he's
got a huge black eye and then they're
like they're like hey sir what are you
enjoying the festivities he's like yeah
they're like what happened to your eyes
like you should see her and i was like
dude then he was like did you see me i
was on the news yeah all the ants like
yeah we saw we said yeah that's what
we're talking about what is like there
is such a special
level of savage that comes from philly
like i know it's crazy it's wise
why is it i don't know
it's
like you i don't know around the birds
it's so hard out there we're in it so
it's tough for us to analyze
like if somebody got arrested for
beating up like a dallas cowboys fan at
an eagles game yeah like you'd get to be
like [ __ ] here [ __ ] yeah you know
joey not some plus yeah it's like yeah
it's a badge of honor right and i don't
know why that is but we're just in it
it's just normal it's like this thing
too like when you do stand up you know
especially like you you tour like as
i've just toured for years and years you
just get like feels for like parts of
your country you're like this is like
this and like when people are like
what's that i'm like dude it is [ __ ]
animals yeah that's philadelphia areas
yeah that is [ __ ] scary there's still
a city where it's like you can still get
got you know what yeah you can still
like it's like check your [ __ ] six
because snowball might be [ __ ] coming
again just the way someone [ __ ] will
talk to someone on the street you're
like jesus christ well dude it's like
there's this but there's this weird
thing of like if you if somebody
wawa is like the perfect thing it's like
if you hold the door for someone at wawa
and they don't say thank you
but it's like you'll do the polite thing
of like i hold there's a common courtesy
of like everybody respects everybody but
the second you break that line of
respect it's like i've seen just you
don't say [ __ ] thank you yeah
you're welcome get one of those if you
don't say thank you it's like well then
you're squaring up in the [ __ ] i
gotta tell you i kind of like that yeah
i love it i love it i'll say this
there's never been a city more
comfortable with people walking around
in broad daylight in pajama bottoms yeah
yeah everybody's okay i like house
[Applause]
i remember this place uh walking into a
place holding the door for a woman
who who was like i can do that thank you
and i was like
what the [ __ ]
um anyone in your family ever owned a pt
cruiser
no okay anyone in your family ever
claimed to have seen a ufo
i don't i mean
i don't think so okay it's pretty good
have you ever bought the floor model of
a tv or an appliance
for sure some like for sure that's
happened okay for sure that's happened
like an astonishing
box but yeah oh yeah yeah
also with a south american in the future
a lot of haggling like it's part of the
culture i mean we're talking like she's
in bloomingdale she's like dude can you
do better i'm like this is not a flea
market
she was like
not like the cashier isn't setting the
prices shut the [ __ ] up
they're not gonna change the price
that's a [ __ ] ralph lauren shirt
you just have to buy it
msrp lady yeah trying to trade her shirt
in for the op
[Laughter]
i have to ask just because it's standard
operating procedure what's the credit
score like
um
i mean probably fine like yeah a
thousand there's no way you have
blemishes at this point it's stellar i
don't know what it is it's got to be
exemplary yeah what kind of what kind of
stuff again no disrespect no i i don't
know i don't know the score but it's
definitely fine admirable yeah yeah of
course yeah um what kind of steel you're
walking around with amex
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the go-to
i have one for touring one for one for
business obviously yeah i actually have
three because i have
one for personal purchases one for
related to podcast stuff of course
touring yeah yeah all right yeah i got a
debit card
i have millions of points yeah really
millions millions oh we have i just
looked this morning what 149 000. holy
[ __ ] it's about four dollars we get a
race car maybe you could you maybe could
actually yeah that's jack [ __ ] when it
comes to amex points i'm waiting for
them to call me be like you have to use
these yeah yeah oh really that's how
trashy we are i looked to see the
equivalent i could get in american
express gift cards that's nice
christmas bonuses coming up everybody
everybody wins do you have a capital one
card
do you want one
i get 500 bucks if i refer i do i get
500 if i sign up a friend
we just started making money dude it's
[ __ ] congratulations
it's
it is and it should be
celebrated i have a real problem
with people that's what i've always
respected about you you don't
a lot of people hide that they fly
private you're like i'm flying i'm doing
it we're blowing it as we make it dude
literally we just lost ten thousand
dollars on a
on a bet that was one of the best once
we hit a certain number on patreon we'll
just go down and blow down you'll make
it tomorrow
you'll make it tomorrow
he just made
it should be celebrated you know you got
to be smart with it but you should have
fun with it and um by the way i could
not do this the tour that i'm on mm-hmm
could not do it uh flying oh no it would
be impossible sure you had your tour is
the stupidest of all time proper nuts
it's proper insane i mean i'm at
over 200 shows
right now on the tour and there's one
year left on the tour can't do that
waiting in the delta lounge
i think the whole tour crew would be
dead there's like [ __ ] six of us
they're all
they're like that right now they go like
we're all wiped and i'm like yeah they
go you really
need to take a break i'm like yeah no
i'm going to do press okay there you go
it's a worker we're boys we're good
friends with potter and we were talking
oh he's great i love yeah he's great um
and we were talking one time he had just
got back opening up speaking of ladies
and gentlemen oh my god the classiest
he's the reason we asked the street name
because he grew up on like you know
route 87 like a proper turnpike so you
could see a toll booth out front of his
house he is one of my absolute favorites
oh dude yeah just with him we were like
we were asking him and he were like
we're like oh he's a guy i was out with
tom he's like i'm just such an idiot
he's like i don't understand levels of
success to the point where he was like
oh what time's your flight you're like
i'm leaving after the [ __ ] show he's
like it didn't even comprehend he's like
i thought he was just gonna go to the
airport
[Laughter]
he's the best he's great did you collect
anything growing up chinese stars
numchucks anything like that beanie
babies commemorative places
there was anybody in the 80s if you were
you had i mean first of all i was taking
taekwondo
yeah
and here's the thing i was pretty highly
ranked
like
where like in retrospect i'm like they
were just like could you pay for another
round and they're like here's another
tiger shulman really
like a 40 year old man was like jesus
christ this kid could kill somebody
he's got to register his hands like and
i was just like
i mean i was this [ __ ] sweet gentle
kid you got a slurpee in your hands and
then we started to get because we're
taking those classes yeah we're getting
into like nunchucks chinese stars
pretending we're nervous
yeah oh yeah i'm talking about giving
myself black eyes
oh [ __ ] beautiful when you when you
first started making money was there any
like silly purchase yeah
i didn't need them something stupid
jet ski yeah well i have two uh you have
two now yeah are they at the house yeah
we're on the we live on the lake so yeah
oh really guys like you can walk out
your backyard and go to a lake i have a
boat and yeah in the backyard damn yeah
cigarette boat no be cool you running
blow what do you mean yeah who the [ __ ]
has a cigarette boat in the lake
that's how little you know about boats
damn dude really he's walked down the
light you got a pool back there too
hot tub
yeah he said 200 cities you idiot
what the [ __ ] who's doing 200 cities of
a goddamn opto
what kind of lawn mower do you have now
that's a john deere
uh
it's a push mower though i want to stay
fine
it's a plug-in takes me about three days
ago that's the trashiest oh
oh the dumbest thing right away was a
pen
a pen like you know i was like in a
store here's the thing you ever feel
guilty in store like i was i felt guilty
to buy something yeah and i was like i
need to use the bathroom you know and
there was like a nice store and then i
was like i'll buy something like and i
bought a pen it was like hundred it was
like 500 dollars what yeah and then i
left and i'm sorry nick what are you
doing no it was like turning four
different colors it's so stupid it was
one of those real like a nice like this
is i mean definitely not be mentioning
that i bought this that was one of those
things you're like keep this to your
[ __ ] salmon
that was so dumb
hey we got an eight ball i got a new pad
i got a pen mm-hmm yeah was it a cross
pen
those were hot for a while those were
hot yeah there was could never write
with them they'd slip out of your hand
mont blanc and then yeah then cartier
yeah those are nice ones
are you double jointed
uh no i used to be able to take my index
fingers and touch
my wrist here for a long time and then
it finally like i could go circus you
know like an x-men like pretty far
but like it used to be able to touch
here and that stopped at some point can
you gleak
no and i wish i it happens only on
yeah yeah i always talk we knew a kid
that could do it and a continuous stream
that's amazing oh dude i don't
understand how it happened now but
we were in a car and we saw him on his
on his school bus we stopped the school
bus and made him get off and do it did
something leak for you dude it was
[ __ ] like stop the bus
we got a gleeker back there
uh have you ever skied in
jeans probably yeah yeah because in uh
that's one of those things like you know
those um
socio-economic bumps of course that we
are skiing well we're in like
minneapolis so like you can go but we're
not buying you all new gear sure yeah so
yeah for sure it was a pair of jeans
everything breaker when you're a
bricklayer you're a kid in that in a
city like that you're just out in jeans
every day in snow and like it's the
worst right it's just there's so much
snow it's cold it's [ __ ] suck
and you're just yeah you're in wet denim
all the time [ __ ] sucks yikes have
you ever had one of those trick
voicemails where you go hello
what was that hello ha ha got ya
no i believe it or not tommy is in at
home
when you guys go out to dinner as a
family as a kid would you ever order the
same thing
like everyone gets the lemon chicken or
the chicken
it wasn't like that okay that was the
[ __ ] worst my dad used to go um
like
he had like this like anxiety of like
let's get home like always so my dad had
to get back to [ __ ] base camp i mean
always everybody get get the whole
[ __ ] show you're at a social anxiety
so like we're all having dinner right
and it's like it would be like if you
guys was that guy why are you looking at
me you're still eating like you're
eating and he would take his bite and he
would go ready to go
like we're all eating right now man and
he's like oh okay and then he would just
be like
and you're like um
hey dad get a sanker or something
you finished your last bite you're ready
now you're like can we just [ __ ] let
me chill for like relax
will you take leftover leftovers home
now like if you go out to a restaurant
if you're not on tour it's you and it's
you and your wife the family go out very
rarely dude i don't really i don't like
to i mean it's it's more like i don't
know i just feel like
whatever you ate is what you ate that's
what i'm saying yeah yeah it's like i'm
not taking this these last four bites of
lemon chicken yeah you know right right
yeah all right if we're doing the
restaurant let's get in let's get into
it okay um i go i go large i know yeah
well you order
first of all
when is the situation where you're not
paying
where where it's not your show
it's rare i would assume agents probably
taking you out they'll pick it up for a
show in the city what if it's you and
rogan out to dinner are you fighting
over the check i tried splitting it no
no i tried to kick you out of this room
i've tried i can check
i've tried to and i've have um given the
card if i know i'm having dinner with
joe or
ahead of time
yes i did that this weekend down the
street that's a nice move got the clutch
yeah
[Laughter]
kind of go to my mom yeah i like i like
you know if you can afford to do it it's
nice to be able to treat people too yeah
also so you don't have that weird let me
get it
like you just go it's taken care of he's
always paid for a [ __ ] everything for
years of course of course yeah yeah he
does okay yeah he does all right that's
good yeah um order appetizers for the
table for everybody you like to do i do
that yeah i do that a lot nice i just i
feel good we get to you know we're on
the road
you when the crew goes out we sit down
i'll be like hey can you bring out like
three of them
yeah you do that like hey get these
we're still we're still figuring it out
let's start dropping stuck in put some
[ __ ] food out here man have you ever
ordered everything off the menu yes
really give me everything i went uh
there was this uh this french guy um
[ __ ] what is his name he owns a tray
uh [ __ ] he's uh i might follow him
on instagram
and he would do these pop-ups that were
just [ __ ] unbelievable okay in austin
no in l.a
um
and i'm trying to remember his name trey
griffith
no no no i was saying trey like french
oh okay his name is uh ludo uh
ludo le febre i don't know i was i
wasn't that bad so he owns uh
i think he has a he might have a
michelin star anyway he would do these
pop-ups in la for a while meaning like
you know just take over
and so the first time i went i had a few
things and i was like
holy [ __ ] this is so like so incredible
like you know like yeah of course so the
next time he had a pop-up and i got a
table i looked at the menu i was like
yes and they're like yes i go yes
everything yeah bring everything run me
through the [ __ ] make me sick yeah
yeah that was the [ __ ] we're just
starting to eat at places where we're
like oh that's i we took there's this
place where we had that was like the
best burger in the city we all took a
bite outside i didn't know rich people
have been eating different things
there's a difference they really it's
there's really here's the let me tell
you the best thing about money
the best thing about money i'm listening
it is not toys
it is not stuff
it is options
options to do things yes that other
people don't want to have to do this and
to make life easier easier
like in other words
a simple version of it would be like
bacon on your burger baking on your
burger
or like to park here's 20 bucks when
you're struggling you're like i'm not
going to waste 20 dollars
i'll drive over there yeah 20 bucks part
the the more and more things come like
that that have uh uh an option for you
yeah right um and you remove any things
i used to like remove anxiety remove
thought remove like yeah i can just put
the car here and not have to worry about
i'm going to get it we're kind of doing
that now but we really can't afford it
well
look this patreon is [ __ ] blowing up
you heard it here www
yeah
billion hours of content but food is
like one of the greatest luxuries oh
it's it's fun being able to eat at a
great place what would be the most if it
sticks out that you ever spent on a meal
i don't know if you want me to tell you
oh yeah we do i want you want to write
it down like a rich guy
[Laughter]
it wasn't long ago
there you go it's
this was uh this is a first finally i
got something pretty elaborate okay
dinner i had okay put a credit card
number down here too just uh
maybe
if you got it
also how much cash you have on you right
now
i don't know okay
let me count
what the [ __ ] let me say it yeah
how many people were there
it's just you
it was uh ladies and gentlemen
it was a group it was okay but i mean
what city
chicago can i say what the number is i
mean do you think we should we talking
honestly this is what people tune in for
all right
52 000
it was my birthday that's more than i
made last year
on the books
no yeah that's your birthday of course
blow it the [ __ ] out is that with tip
that was with tip
all right with tip
hey what's 5 at 52 000
i figured with wine and tax it's really
only 38 grand
holy [ __ ] why we're in this world 52
jihads what is the most you've ever
given as a wedding gift
and then also i want to hear if you were
coming to like just our wedding you know
what i mean not like obviously the gift
would probably have been like which
you're invited
52 000 times my friend either way send a
gift
like it might have been like a niece or
a nephew or something yeah when burt was
on bert said he's like i try to take
care of their honeymoon oh that's a
[ __ ] move that's a that's a gangster
move tim said he had given ben
thousand dollars really
yeah because yeah yeah yeah
jesus christ who's got the [ __ ]
bentley
what are you doing 200 and a card what's
going on it better be up now blender
[Laughter]
hey thanks for the george foreman group
like i don't know if you have a niece or
a nephew like nieces or nephews well
that's the thing is i haven't been like
to like somebody that close yeah and i
haven't had like the weddings like they
happen in your life for like a few years
and then they're like i haven't been
invited to a wedding and that's probably
pretty true yeah do you have anybody
hitting me up for cash i have had that
happen really yes a large amount
uh more than dinner no
no
i've had people like you know investment
opportu like they're like hey you want
to just get in on a sports drink
a lot of sports and i'm like nah those
are hot right now and you know what the
funny thing is is that you could tell
they're doing sales lines they're like
you know sports drinks are one of the
most popular you're like i know you why
are you talking about you're reading
wikipedia right now it's actually a 1.7
billion dollars
stop with this you got the dog in the
car yeah jesus christ uh i had a guy one
time this is terrible this dude i know
for a long time
because i'm in a jam
for rent and this is like the 29th he's
like if i don't have rent well how long
ago was this this was like
five years ago okay so you're cooking
i'm doing i'm doing
well rant you must be like what the
[ __ ] right he's like you know
i got a lake house [ __ ] he goes
i'll send you a jet ski
rents do and um if i could
you know if you could help me out
otherwise i'm going to be out and i was
like jesus christ all right um i go well
i'm like
traveling
i was like international i was like dude
i'm not gonna get back and he was like
it was potter
and i remember being like [ __ ] um
you know i don't have a checkbook with
me i'd have to like call a business
manager and it was a whole thing right
now and then it was like they would
think that's shady you're for sure yeah
you're in europe somewhere it was like a
saturday so i was like they're not even
like in the office oh man this is
somebody who's not um i'm not regular in
communication sure this guy does not
reach out for the favor you don't know
how to be a scumbag if you're making
moves like that you know where you are
it's [ __ ] make sure it's banking
hours yeah exactly all that stuff so
here's what i'm doing saturday and he's
telling me i'm gonna get like kicked out
i'm like [ __ ] i'm like well it's
saturday i don't you know i don't know
what to do
i also have like work i go i have shows
yeah and i do my shows and then i fly
back
he's like uh
hey man is there any way you can send me
that i'm like it's the third now
yeah so you're not he's like yeah they
they told me if
if i get it to him i can still stay and
he's waiting on it yeah so i was like
okay i go okay i go i'll you know i mean
like where do i go i go i go just send
it to them send them
set of the thing and then you know i
rent 30 grand a month
yeah it was like that's like when uh i
forget who it was it was like on that
documentary broke or whatever or
something it was like nobody needs ten
thousand dollars it was like it was like
people the second like athletes get
their checks or whatever it's like no
one needs
ten thousand dollars they've made it
this far without it like it's not gonna
change their life they're just gonna
blow it you don't have to
pay for
things for people you know with your
money yeah that's like they were like
auditing people the guy's like yeah i
pay for 348 cell phones right now you're
like what the [ __ ] it's just like
[ __ ] 20 grand a month in t-mobile
[ __ ] plans hear that patty you're cut
off as of right now
um you eat your pizza crust
yeah okay yeah you own a tux
no
you don't know how many suits you own
suits though right i have a bunch of
suits bunch of suits name brand or
they're [ __ ] designers
cookies yeah yeah
they are no [ __ ] not today's man or
anything like that
now they're like briony yeah yeah i
don't even know what that is what he
just said he's dropped a couple things
i'm like oh yeah yeah
is that a kind of oyster
are the jet skis in the water like right
there like if you landed at your house
right now we walked straight to your
backyard i get on a jet you got a
helipad i'm cruising do you no but i
would you have a submarine like to
[ __ ] get one
no so the jet skis are on lift
submarines right so yeah they're out of
the water
and they go drop down so you have a
little uh like a little uh slip dock
boat house yeah whatever yeah yeah what
kind of kind of boat is it pontoon what
do you got it's a nautique yeah see i
don't know what what is that it's a it's
pretty dope
it's nice yeah yeah outboard inboard
what are we doing here center console
inboard no uh whatever right side right
side yeah yeah who's driving it you
you're the captain no no no no no no no
no no
do you have the same pilot that flies
the private jet or is it who's ever
there
okay yeah still pretty good though it's
pretty great how do you feel about
banana pudding i like how you're like
still pretty good um
i mean i'll [ __ ] with banana pudding
yeah was there a dish you know this boat
is sick well this is like if guy fieri
was a boat
it's got a smoker on it yeah that's
pretty cool
god damn it man
we only have time for a couple of more
here too okay but what was the last uh
what i was gonna say was there a family
dish that was that was revered in the
family your aunts uh
something i always like
certain like you know you get used to
everyone has like a [ __ ] distorted
sense of their mother's cooking yeah you
gotta try my mom's meatloaf you're like
i'm good yeah um cardboard yeah i uh you
know i i like to make this peruvian dish
called lomo saltado which is like a beef
dish okay potatoes and rice and onions
and corn it's very very like kind of
renowned in cuisine
and so her version of that was like my
one of my favorite things right yeah all
right real quick
sleeping king-sized bed i assume yeah
how many pillows are on the bed a lot
how many pills do you sleep with i like
to use one like kind of
structured like a thicker one okay and
then a softie underneath it right okay
sure and then i put i put a wrap around
my eyes nice and i put a
sleep guard in my mouth and then i
started doing this thing where i tape my
mouth i just got the tape my wife just
bought me the tape it's pretty cool it
works it is it just came yesterday it it
forces your nose more yeah yeah yeah
well you can still breathe you can and
you and you'll feel more rested you do
feel more spin hot guys
ladies you're loosening up no sleep
happening machine no sleep apnea machine
all right that's pretty good um pillow
between your legs
no if i here's the thing if i want if i
remember when like you know if i'm kind
of like
whatever i don't know if it's kind of
getting into the morning and i want to
sleep where i'm on my side and i grab
one i'll do it but it's not fixed gotcha
where it's every time but i i do like
when i remember to because you just yes
it aligns your hips more
his and her sinks in the bathroom yes uh
what's the shower like probably pretty
banging it's a it's a i mean it's not
like super crazy do you have do you have
a stand-up shower and a tub separate yes
and there's a steam in this there's
steam in the shower too do you do it
yeah i love the steam great steam's
great
do you pee in the shower [ __ ] yeah i
don't understand yeah you got it like
what are people doing do you brush your
teeth in there no really no i don't i
brush my kind of toothpaste do you use
um i [ __ ] around with them um i have the
uh i mean i'll i'll do crest i'll do the
uh really the baking baking soda that
that arm and hammer armament hammer one
i like that once you do that it's tough
to go back to the other stuff that's
kind of my primary yeah what about this
are you a bar guy or a body body wash i
prefer body wash but we have
you know soap bars yeah loofah's in
there what are you scrubbing yourself
with uh there have been they i feel like
they just they're all sudden they're
gone they're always gone yeah you use
them and then they look funny and then
you get somebody tosses them but i like
the gel how do you dry yourself off when
you get out do you do like all you wait
do you walk out and then dry yourself
off or do you do it in the shower i
don't do it in the shower you have
somebody that does it for you i usually
do it
like prince hakeem yeah i uh no you know
the towel is usually right on the hook
outside okay um i get out i um yeah i
kind of do like you know go down legs
are all and i'm hairy dude like yeah got
a towel off pretty aggressively yeah
waiting around with it different radio
in the shower or anything like that i
have a little uh well have a bluetooth
speaker in the shower smart okay and i
also have like the sonos system built in
to the bathroom yeah you do yeah did you
build this house or did you move into it
no but it was it was a newly built house
so i bought it before it was done yeah
gotcha
brought the jet skis with
you got any heated floors in there no
that's such a dope move no it's a real
power flex to the heated driveway if
you're in lake montana he doesn't need
it you don't need it down there yet no
no shoveling no no it's hot as [ __ ]
there keep the butter on the counter at
the house you put it in the fridge
i'll put it in the fridge okay but
there's always a covered tray on the
counter because some like yeah yeah yeah
yeah who goes who's going to the grocery
store you got people to do that or you
going to the grocery store i don't go to
the grocery store yes [ __ ] yeah i got a
grocery store ever been in a tornado
um there's been tornadoes i've i've
lived places where there was a tornado
there's never actually been in one no no
but multiple hurricanes
had to evacuate like several times do
you sleep with your socks on no what do
you sleep in just boxers no t-shirt no
and you're a boxer man yeah boxer briefs
yeah boxer
yeah yeah yeah you wear uh shoes in the
house
i mean
yes i try like i prefer when i remember
to take them off okay so i don't like
tracking [ __ ] everywhere of course but i
i definitely walk in sometimes i mean
you know if you have guests come over
for dinner you're gonna make them take
their shoes no no i don't i don't do
that would you enjoy doing that at
someone's house like if you went over to
[ __ ] whoever's house like take your
shoes off i don't really like that yeah
it sucks right i think that's cool what
are we [ __ ] eleven yeah like we're
adults i mean i have asian friends and
you know you kind of gotta you do what
they say
but yeah i prefer to just keep keep them
on yeah do you wipe back to front or
front to back
uh front to back do you have a bid front
to back you go inside no no start
like
up right okay yeah so front to back
front direction okay yeah gotcha uh i
have the built-in the primary like my
master toilet has the built-in washlet
so you just press the button and it like
streams clean jobs that is such a game
changer yeah i know yeah and you feel
like a monster when you're not home when
you're you're doing raw poop somewhere
[Laughter]
that's kind of why i don't want to do it
because it's like that you know because
like they're not all home games that
feel that feeling that cleanse like this
of like
of like the warm stream cleaning right
in your [ __ ] house
yeah also somebody said you have a
coffee machine in your
bed in your bathroom
um
is that true that we were somebody just
like a mr coffee or like an espresso
machine dunk a whole dunkin donuts
[Laughter]
what happened was when i was uh
we looked at houses like this a while
ago one of the houses where you took a
tour they're like oh and in the master
bedroom they're like open some cabinet
and this thing slid out and they're like
there's a coffee machine here
and my wife was like yeah why don't we
put a coffee machine like why i have to
go down
so there's like this little area in our
bedroom that has you know
i don't know it's just like a like a
little corner
yeah and
she just put a
like in a spread you know like a capsule
coffee that's pretty close you're going
to wake up and you just make a cocktail
you got tv in the bedroom yeah you sleep
with the tv on no i can't really i i
i do that thing where i um
if i close my eyes and the tv's on i'll
be list i can't shut off the list yeah
of course
hellman's or miracle whip
mayonnaise-wise
i think i'll go miracle-whip
kind of trashy right are you [ __ ]
kidding me whoa
you made it like almost an hour you were
scot-free yeah
holy [ __ ] i mean but here's the thing
i'm not gonna
you know it's not gonna neither one's
gonna like
make me not i love mayo sure like people
you make a sandwich at the house you
have a miracle up in the house uh
i have to [ __ ] you gotta check you
don't even know well yeah i could
probably someone's making it for me you
know really yeah i'm not
do you have a chef
no
you have somebody that makes lunch and
stuff like that though
sometimes
the [ __ ] boss ladies i know
listen
the miracle whip aside pretty flawless
otherwise dude you're [ __ ] all class
bro oh thanks man you're the [ __ ]
boss thanks dude look at this it is
shockingly rare that people come out as
scot-free as you have done really dude
it's like you and chase momentary are in
yeah really you but yeah but you've
always you can tell you've always
held yourself to a higher regard even
before i can't even hold the jet skis
against you because they're [ __ ] in
the water you have you're living a lake
i thought they would be like on the side
of the house on a trailer or something
just telling them behind the porsche
yeah damn wow he's trying to [ __ ] i'm
honored man this is that's a good score
yeah
did this yeah yeah no [ __ ] and he was
all [ __ ] oh dude he had a guy with
nickel on him right outside the door
yeah yeah
an ex-cop freddie no no he's like you
driving watching the car yeah no what
was he he had a [ __ ] wild he had a
name that you would expect jazz bomb
with his bodyguard oh yeah yeah yeah it
was something
bobby angels or something like that
gang
brand new book out right here get the
[ __ ] out i'd like to play alone please
mr tom segora yes thank you guys
anything else you want the folks out
there to know no i mean i'm on i'm on a
crazy tour if you want to come see me on
tour tomsgrow.com tour for tickets
that's it
[ __ ] unbelievable a lot of those
shows were sold out i was perusing the
website
those [ __ ] early promo codes really
get it done no papering going on there
huh
not a lot of morning radio in your
future i can tell you that right now the
kids do it all right kippy what do you
got for us guys we're all over the road
as well check us out the the links in
the description check out the patreon
the whole nine yards we [ __ ]
appreciate it love yous tom we love you
thank you so much
absolutely gang we love you and we'll
see you next week